so you want to do like a lot of your
scenes with an animated character so how
does that work since you know that's not
real yeah a vivid imagination you're
staring into you know your middle space
of nothing most of you basically trying
not to lose your mind on a daily base
ardh yeah it's I you know you get used
to it it's like okay great I don't have
to wait on other actors to show up I can
create my own actor in front of my face
and also you viens can tell if you are
looking at something too far away if
your products here there's a
triangulation of your eyes you have to
like train your eyes music video for
ugly dolls and they are like here are
the characters and I felt I was I I was
like I'm gonna suck at this and you did
a whole movie like that I can't imagine
when we work with this stuffed animal
that's sitting there yeah it's it's a
it's an early stuffed version of Sonic
and his eyes kind of look like Jim's on
the screen it's kind of glued on you
know kind of an early crude plushy
speaking of movies in roles you always
take I said this backstage but we both
love singing and you're so good at it
[Applause]
and they just can do everything they're
singing they're dancing or act it's so
cool to do it it's like the old studio
days you know you gotta sing dancing all
of it right you know what it is and
maybe Jim can it feels the same way I
was always just a mimic I could always
hear rattling rhythms of dialogue I can
hear rhythms of music and I could hear
the pitch and I would just emulate
singers that I liked yes yeah you know I
could sing it just was that's kind of
where it came from did you I was allowed
to go outside
[Laughter]
so I used to like you know yeah i'ma
tape Johnny Mathis and people like that
I used to come up with singing
impressions so yeah we can we can
basically fake our way through anything
yeah so can women don't why would you
fake it four or five times
[Laughter]
oh did I say too much stop three I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this